[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right my innovate interface says the
internet can totally see you now so
hello everyone
even though I don't know if anyone is
here but we are fully operational and we
are about to start with the meadow arena
the meadow Arena already started so
we're gonna check up on some of the
games just let me know if everything is
working properly very well Andre sonido
hey hello man thank you for for the
comment so I know everything is ok if
everything is ok with the audio and
video we can check out out some of the
games so here's one just about a start
between by quadric sand Eric Eric rivet
so it's the same as every time
oops sorry about that I seem to have
forgotten to switch the interface this
is the interface from the previous video
so let me just switch that yeah I was
sure I missed something but yeah here we
go yeah this is the first activate all
right here we go I think that should do
it
a little a little lighting and I think
yeah I think we're good to go
yeah I thought something was weird but I
couldn't couldn't put my finger on it
for those of you who still want to join
I do join the links to the tournaments
are in the description below you have
joined meadow arena and also you can
join the Friday arena so there are 360
people in the meadow arena it's a
tournament for players below 1700 rating
as you might imagine you guys know that
but yeah
sorry about the mix-up with with the
interface
entity clash Royale okay man drop a
challenge and I think we'll have a time
for for a game or two between the two
tournaments hello John Brian how you
doing man
Nomad Meadows not one one four tricks
like he could maybe do the stay like if
I tell him like made of stay then he
sometimes he stays sometimes he doesn't
but he he's not trained
thanks potential all right so we have by
quadric versus Eric provide the first
game we're checking out and already a
lot of action on the board so let's see
what's happening here the the black King
quite loose and what's happening here
will the king capture that no the pawn
will capture that and then you I guess
you started attacking the Queen has to
move like here yeah
or there so some if some captures happen
yeah
it looks weird but black black just
might be okay yeah this is the meadow
arena
both DeMarco thanks for thanks for
joining us now even ESCO gaming channel
also joining us
even you reach you join by clicking on
the link in the description below yes I
have played Final Fantasy 9 several
times actually so it's it's a good game
if you cannot join the tournament it
either means your rating is too high or
you haven't played at least 30 rated
games so here black seems to have
survived everything and now we are going
into a rook and pawn endgame so it's
gonna be it's gonna be fun
Vibha agrawal there we go man well I
wouldn't call myself a gamer I did play
I did play a lot of games in my youth
but now I I mostly watch the the
cinematics on YouTube from from newer
games even ESCO you want to be a mod
sure man there you go there you go man
don't abuse your power alright what's
happening here you capture and go back
and you try and create a passed pawn
here while the white rook is pretty much
stuck there ya go moving with the rook I
guess yeah that's the stuff and now
create a passed pawn and it should be
winning yeah now Kay well what's that
trade rooks and you win yeah just push
upon or that one I don't know yeah seems
to seems to be working the king is just
outside of the square of the pawn so not
a problem yeah a lot of a lot of League
players are starting to get into chests
now I know Volvo was always into chess
and I never knew that other other
streamers were also enjoying it no I'm
not a grandmaster I am far from it
smokestack lightning all rights most
smokestack lightning is just starting
out his game against forget [ __ ] [ __ ]
hitter on
I've played magic once with a friend who
is a pretty good player he tried to
explain it to me but I didn't feel like
learning a new card game yeah I've been
to some ice channel we we're having like
another stream a few days from now it's
gonna be gonna be trying out for players
chests I've never tried that so it
should be fun I think Geary will also be
there and the vidit so should be should
be a lot of fun have I played ultra
bullet yes I have it's I mean I do enjoy
hyper bullet but ultra bullet it's just
a whole other universe i I don't know
who techno blade is but I will check it
out things
thanks for the for the notification is
there any free chess engine that I would
recommend pretty much all chess engines
are free especially the one you use on
on websites sometimes you have to you
know buy their premium pack to get like
deeper analysis or something like that
but even the free version is more than
enough unless you're planning like doing
some super deep analysis when will morph
you return ah very soon as soon as we
catch a break from all the online events
that are happening
ah
techno blade is a Minecraft youtuber
okay so minecraft youtubers are also
getting into chess seems like everyone's
getting into chess
alright what's happening here black set
up a very nice defense here along the
seventh rank and also the knight is
doing a nice job here so yeah we'll see
captors now this point is weak oh that's
a free Queen damn yeah that that had to
hurt that had to hurt but I think black
will continue this the rooks still
defense from mate and well you know he
still he still has a knight so I guess
anything can happen the stigma of being
nerdy is gone I don't think it was it
was ever there
all right and this is now ending very
soon
yep that's mate so good game good game
Jorge Tehran all right let's check out
some other players from deeper down the
rabbit hole as we usually say oh I got
matter the second this year is he
playing let's see how he's doing
whoever whoever you are out of matter
the second let's see you what you are
winning this pawn oh you will trade
Queens first and then you're gonna go
after the pawn okay
and this Bishop is beautiful so should
be should be much better for white but
we'll see what happens or not yeah
especially now with the back rank mate
and everything very nicely done alright
let's see what we have
mm looking for some looking for some
nice handles yeah
headless chests man where did the
headless chessmen go alright let's see a
game by headless chess man from
Kazakhstan he's currently waiting to be
paired
where are you headless chess man
yeah it doesn't seem to be pairing him
house I was gonna I wanted to see a game
by headless chessmen but we're gonna
have to find someone else
mr nada alright not playing okay here we
have a game so let's check this one out
yeah the the simple water championship
you haven't if you haven't seen it do
check it out
another another epic brilliancy by by a
gamma Torino I'm coming to some ice
channel I think we agreed on like this
Sunday I think it's on Sunday all right
I will have to check for the four the
four player session for the four players
chest session who do I think will win
the wind or asabi well everyone has a
one has a chance now it's a knockout
phase in a knockout phase it's
impossible to predict but obviously the
the favourites are well pretty much
everyone's a favorite those are all
incredibly good players especially in a
rapid time format so I don't think you
can you can mix any picks here am I
going to collaborate with Hikaru yes I
might we might do some some content
together well we'll see hopefully yes
could be it could be nice and wind c11
wins as touka Mimi
loses on time all right so let's check
up on some speed monster let's see if
speed monster has the speed and he's
berserk King so okay speed Monster
no I've never played four person chess
I've I've heard it's it's possible and
that it's like like two people first I
thought it was two against two but it's
actually not it's every man for himself
and then you kind of have to like have
some dirty gentleman agreements like
let's now go after him and then you know
they trick you and then you guys go
after the other guy and you know
anything had happened or or so I've
heard
we're gonna see all right so how is
speed monster doings he's offering a
queen trade but now Bishop characters
and f6 could be very strong
if takaka spots it so you cannot trade
Queens because you lose a piece and then
you just open up the the black King
there don't seem to be any yeah you
can't now its mate all rights mate ah he
missed that Quincy to was made King h1
and then you sacrifice the Queen with
rook delivering checkmate oh but it's
still there he can still do it
I've got matters dog thanks for the
contribution
man yep that's a mate will oh but it's
not his move he played rook b8 wow
that's that's a shame but he is up a lot
of material so shouldn't be a problem
don't beat revisiting four players
chests okay well white is completely
lost however black is extremely long
time now extremely like 34 seconds is
quite a lot but okay what are we gonna
have a draw by repetition yeah white
what is happy with that obviously
oh this is this is good
everyone teams up against visit all
right I will use that I will use that
strategy 22 seconds by speed monster
okay now you cannot block check oh this
is this is getting very intense black
had a lot of chances to finish the game
but he needs to do something quick how
do I feel about MVL drinking more than
me I I guess your think you're referring
to sips of water yeah I guess he did
have some throat problems so I guess
that's why he beat me although I really
drink a lot of water so it I was
actually very impressed that he drank
more water than me like I always have
this like huge bottle and then I just
you know sip all day long and now it's a
white who's long time this is uh this is
one intense game like this is impossible
to predict
eight seconds for Wow yeah time is low
for both prayer warrior shoutouts from
Kenya and now white is down a rook and
it's it's a it's a flag off so and it's
actually white who loses on time this
was this was an incredible game so I do
hope you enjoyed that let's check up on
a few more games big machine wow that's
a good handle big machine
what would a big machine be okay so
we're already in the endgame a rook is
blundered here so white big machine
grabs it and now white is completely
winning up a whole rook so let's see
with 35 seconds can pig machine do it
or can black think of something maybe I
don't see what it could be
okay he had a he had an idea but it's
not gonna work yeah you don't trade
works here at all like you have to you
have to save the rook if you're trying
to trying to go into flag mode but like
you can just hide it on DF file and
that's pretty much it
ah the time control is three plus zero
so normal normal blitz
yeah the lockdown is completely off in
Croatia
well mostly there are still some
regulations but for the most part it's
you know it's pretty much there is no
lockdown all right so tricky losses in
big machine wins as black has nothing
more to try here London blue so that's
like London blue from India so that's
like like deep blue button but from
London bring Vichy on the podcast yeah I
do
I will try if you guys enjoy podcast you
can check out Benny's perpetual Church
podcast I think he had vision on one of
his podcast so if you guys haven't
checked it out do check it out have you
ever been to Vardhan of course
before all right what's happening here
can black do something here huh yeah
it almost looks good but white should be
completely winning here
yeah of course it's it's hard to get
Vichy to to you know spend the spends
time on a podcast but he is currently I
believe locked down in Germany and you
know I don't know how much how much he
can do from there so it might be
possible I guess
the sofa pillow is very cute okay
London blue loses in time but he also is
in a completely lost position so it's
not not nothing to be worried about if
the night wasn't here he'd actually have
a draw or maybe more but definitely a
draw
but not like this all right Tea Party
that's a that's a good handle let's see
how mister Tea Party is doing offering a
queen trade where we have here captures
captures and it's white up the exchange
and up upon well white should oh and now
white wins back the exchange okay black
wins back the exchange
all right yeah I guess you go all the
way back yeah I don't think you go there
since you kind of want to allow this
pond to start marching forward Oh buddy
I'm black black we'll grab one of the
works maybe not right away I guess he's
not in a hurry oh okay he will
oh no it's black black is up a full rook
I didn't even spotted the rukon I faith
Wow
okay then that's of course black is
completely winning but dude the two
passports could pose some problems so
you never know Rakesh Sharma
there we go man why is there no
increment I know and no one likes
increment
now I've never visited India but it is
on my to-do list or rather to visit list
no I don't think future loses the Magnus
due to a mental barrier I I think future
losses because Magnus is simply better
so I I don't think it's odd or anything
do I know a game where pawn is promoted
to a bishop or a rook yes I know several
such games all right so now black will
attempt to to checkmate white am i
strong in Evans gambit mm that's a very
relative idea I I do enjoy playing it
that's for sure and you know between
opponents of similar strength to mine I
do both win and lose games and black
will flag white instead of delivering
checkmate or if he if he's not careful
he's gonna do a threefold repetition
okay there's a pawn okay so he Flags in
but if it works all right so what do we
have
589 players yeah if anyone is just
joining in the chat do check out the
links in the description below they will
take you to the arena you can still join
still very early the leaders are just
world one six one two is on 24 points
you can still catch up to everyone I
have a matter of the second in second
place also Burger King every game let's
check out vissarion how is Vissarion
doing that's that's one of its Ariane is
one of the dragons from Game of Thrones
if I'm not mistaken
Sonic you joined the arena by clicking
on the link in the description no I'm
not I'm not playing at the moment these
tournaments I organized on Fridays are
for for showcasing subscribers games so
you guys can play and I'm just gonna
show a few of your games and I don't
know I thought it was a nice idea I've
never tried the Slav or studied it or
anything but it seems like a lot of
players have played it in the Magnus
Invitational so might be we might be
seeing more of it what's the difference
between Mather and Friday arena
well meadow arena okay there's okay
you've defended mate meadow arena is
only four players rated lower than
17-hundred and the Friday arena is open
for everyone so it doesn't matter if you
rate it 1100 or 3100 everyone everyone
can play
are those chess trophies yes they are
their Chester office in the background I
don't know I guess Prague was taking
some some break or maybe working on his
chess but a lot of tournaments were were
postponed adjourned you know cancelled
so we're not seeing we're not seeing a
lot of anyone other than the absolute
elite players who are constantly playing
online tomorrow is car pops birthday
which game which carpet game would you
like to see opinion on the Kings Indian
defense for black well it's a it's very
enjoyable to play a lot of attacking
chances so if you enjoy complicated
positions where anything can happen you
will not go wrong with the Kings Indian
no I'm not officially an international
master or anything I'm only only a
candidate master in Croatia
which age is the best to become a
professional in chess I guess any age
like if you if you're 50 and you decide
it's time to become a professional then
you do it I think I think Adolphe
Anderson started playing like really
really late in his life
and he still achieved like okay it was a
different time of course but if you set
your mind to it you will not maybe reach
the absolute top level but you you will
still be able to make progress you want
to get creation citizenship how hard is
it to get it I don't know you should you
should ask us part of he was able to get
it how was my experience playing chess
with Indian youtubers it was very very
eventful they're there they're great
guys and you know obviously enjoying
chess a lot so I enjoy it when whenever
someone promotes chess so I was very
happy to join them for their stream I
should put together a world bullets
tourney yeah I'm planning some bigger
tournaments but for the moment it seems
likely chess is still having some issues
with their servers so I think any larger
tournaments wouldn't really wouldn't
really be possible but I as I hear
they're they're working on on solving
the issue
all right so black down a night but he
will make some nice rook lifts maybe
bring this rope here bring the other
work here make some threats and the
queen is pretty much stuck here guarding
this pawn so we'll see okay that's not
really helping all that much Vishnu
thank you thanks for India man yeah you
have to double up here and what is of
course still better but he will have to
he will have to work a bit more who is
my favorite youtuber I don't I don't
think I have one yeah pretty sure I
don't have like a favorite one I'm not
I'm not watching all that much
yeah as yes I am looking forward to the
four player chest with with Alexandra
and visitin Giri
I've never played it but some I said
that it was it was very enjoyable I'm
gonna I'm gonna believe him
yeah I've seen I've seen plenty of
videos from coffee chests they they make
really really nice videos and it's
always an interesting game so it's yeah
it's gonna get a queen against two rooks
now and yeah that's that's a shame
that's checkmate
okay yeah I thought that was gonna
happen no the other book takes but okay
still this guy can come over here and
all right Wow stalemate
no okay you don't this doesn't happen
often but it does happen so there we
have it from being down a piece to being
completely winning to stalemate so a
very very vengeful game yeah we will
have the audience saga at some point I
thought you guys were actually gonna
vote for the idea in saga after the
couple Blanca saga but you guys voted
more fee and I'm actually very very
happy that you guys chose Morphy I mean
I would have enjoyed the idea in saga
just as much but the Morphy saga is much
shorter so I thought yeah maybe just
let's do that one Magnus sixteen Carlson
also from Norway all right here's a here
we have a Carlson fan let's see how he
how he does against Sebastian sanda so
okay offering a trade of bishops and
what's going on here what black is up a
night it's gonna be very tough for for
the young Magnus here Sean Chong thanks
for the things for the Confucian man
ah thank you for for all the
contribution with yeah with with the
infamous attack hey Oliver Mortimer
thanks a lot man thanks for the
contribution does vidit have what it
takes to be a top 5 player I don't know
I mean that's up to him he is very young
he is you know he's very strong if he I
guess if he chooses to you know further
work on his chest of course I believe
everything can happen all right so let's
check out ring bells ring o bells all
right let's see ringer bells if you are
18 and about 1,500 how far can you get I
don't know what just happened here
ok white immediately resigned ok so
let's try to find a game that's just
starting out well depends on how much
you how much you work on it how much you
give yourself into it I don't think
there's like of course everything is
easier when you're a child you can learn
much faster and of course in a different
way but it's never never too late ok
let's try and get ok this one's all
almost just started and it's a really
crazy position
finneus freak vs Chris the pilot I like
the I like the handle Chris the pilot I
don't know if it means something or
maybe this gentleman is actually a pilot
named Chris
all right we're gonna we're gonna check
up on an Yellin ass game after this one
favorite kind of cookies are no favorite
kind of cookies yeah I don't know
the Nakamura responds the Carlson's
tweet I don't think he did I don't I
don't think he will or maybe he will and
Chris the pilot resigns as he is down
not just a queen but also a whole other
material
how long does it take for 1,200 to reach
2,000 I would say 1 1 good year with
intense studying or maybe 2 years it
depends on how intense your studying is
deep though for a 7 thanks a lot man
yeah I'm often asked this which book I
would recommend to a beginner but it's
it's not everyone would it depends on
what you think by beginner
for example if if you just started out
and you only know how each piece moves
then you would need a different book
than if you already know how to play I
guess but I don't know I I always
recommend couple Blancas chest
fundamentals and I don't think you can
go wrong with that it's I mean it's the
world champion capablanca explaining
chess you know in it's in all of its
glory I think throughout some 13 or 14
of his games so I think it's it's it's a
good start but I think whichever game
you you whichever book you grab you will
not you know make a bad bad move thanks
mr. Alfred toric you also miss any bunch
of game all right we I have one ready
actually I have it open in my tab I was
gonna publish it after after all of this
but I might be able to do it today since
today's a rest day inland Doris
[Music]
gosh can I do a collab stream with Eric
Rosen I could but I don't do all that
many collabs simply because I don't
stream I mean most other people stream I
mostly make videos so it's not all that
easy for me to make collaboration videos
but who knows in the future I might do
do more of those but then I have to make
less videos so you know and whenever I
do something and make less videos then
you guys are like yeah that was good but
you made less videos so like you guys
want more more games that are currently
happening but you also want the morphe
saga but you also enjoyed the podcast
but you also would like some of this and
that and you know it's I only have 24
hours a day
Ramaswamy Rajic aru Kumar with three
openings you must know the Kings gambit
the Evans gambit and of course the Royal
opus that's a joke of course I mean any
any opening you enjoy you should know
that one I'm drinking some bottled water
I mean like a normal water tap water
all right so the bishop prevents best
queen g5 so how do you how do you try
that okay he wants to get Queen g6 into
checkmate white howlite defend how will
white defend if if it's at all possible
like Queen here then check Queen g5 is
possible but I guess Queen here h6 maybe
but then you have Queen f4 and if Queen
g6 then you block with Queen g3 I guess
something like that might be possible I
can't fool you you know it's vodka huh
I'm King h1
yeah King each one also works what was
my last job I my last job was I worked
as a graphic designer doing some flyers
and you know some some website editing
stuff like that
alright so that's a nice check going
after the b7 pawn and will black move
the King or block with the bishop that's
that's interesting
what do I think about the TV show money
heist Ivan I haven't seen it like
Netflix is always pushing it like you
should watch it but I haven't seen it
people say it's really good I just I
just finished watching the blacklist
so now I'm searching for something else
to watch so if you guys if you guys say
money heist is is you know a good to
watch then I guess maybe I could give it
a try
money heist is amazing okay
all right the roof okay now threatening
checkmate how do you prevent this roblox
okay that was a free rook so maybe
capturing the rook first then blocking
so okay Bishop prevents this so you
don't have to worry about any perpetual
it's still a very interesting game money
heist is a must okay
ah the suits are awesome
yeah I've seen suits I think I have two
more episodes and then I'm done with
suits but I really enjoyed suits I
haven't seen new episodes of Rick and
Morty I'm waiting for the entire season
to finish and then I'm just gonna binge
the entire fourth season advice on
becoming better at chess I think it's
mmm during the podcast mvl said that
when he was younger he was doing a lot
of work on openings and you know of
course studying the endgame and you know
doing puzzles of course you have to do
puzzle studies and stuff and then later
after he became stronger it's you know
of course opening preparation for the
matter but mostly mostly solving puzzles
as you you have to keep your your brain
sharp I stopped playing rather late but
that doesn't really matter I mean if you
enjoy it okay
it's a weird this is now
there's this okay
and in between move before the main one
I guess but with seven seconds on the
clock will see all the Rays are abdul
Sattar of who has a better future and he
loses on time but he was about to get
checkmate it's a good game Ilana
very nicely done
yeah I haven't seen all that many of us
a tour of games but what I've seen in
the world blitz championship he's he's
amazing
like the game he played against Magnus
was just uh he was I think he was
winning and then of course he couldn't
he couldn't play the entire game you
know with with that same strength but he
really outplayed him in the opening and
you know a little bit in the middle game
well opinion and English opening yes
right
you know people play it and there are
really a lot of good games that we cover
on the channel it's played every day you
know the like the other day we had the
quiet line of the Englishmen we had the
names of each line D for blocking d5 and
well it's a nice opening to know I think
it's something that everyone should know
I've never studied it myself but I've
never studied most openings like I said
I'm currently currently studying up on
the RIT more to be more precise the
United 3d five rarity
this is something that like if you want
to be a mod you have to have a profile
photo I can just you know make anyone a
mod I have to see that you're a real
person status and the chest manga it is
like it's almost it's almost there like
you can almost feel it make an opening
video on the Evans gambit yeah I I am
planning to do it all so I need to
improve on it as you know people do go
for the shop c5 Italian quite a lot in
blitz and well even in classical but
it's been a very long time since I've
checked it out am I happy with my life
yes I am
yes I am
arjan Aria Gupta who has a profile photo
says he wants to be a mod alright man
there we go you are now a mod oh no we
don't have all that many mods on the
stream but it's the slow chat is turned
on so I don't think it we're having any
problems in the chat what about Du Bois
is he better than Fallujah I believe so
but he's also older and more experienced
so I don't think he would beat Fallujah
in a bullet match or yeah I don't think
like it's hard to say if anyone would
but in longer time formats I would still
I still think dubov is is the stronger
player
what is a mod mod is a person who makes
sure that everything is you know working
nicely in the chat that no one is using
any foul language or insulting anyone or
you know he's making the chat a friendly
environment if you will I am federated
but I think like 1900 it's been it's
really been a while since I played a
federated game
do I want to know the mods personally
yeah sure
like I wouldn't like maybe if we had a
good stream and then if we all lived in
the same area maybe after a stream we
could all grab a beer I think that'd be
nice but I don't think it's possible
unless I get like mods from my hometown
even ESCO is the mod he's from my
hometown but he's too young to drink
beer so that's that's gonna have to wait
good game a good game last three against
the meat 397 how are we doing here ten
more minutes in the meadow arena and the
chess world still leading fall by manali
ratted pants Eric I got matter the
second Oregon matter to Christine I know
six Bouvet King a blindfold chess all
day I think we've seen at least one game
by blind for chess all day but we're
gonna check out not on this dream in the
previous dream s mimin asks cross and
vs. Fischer who who would you bet your
money on yeah that's right we've
answered that question like pretty much
in in every stream so if the chat is
willing I will let the chat answer you
but it's I mean it's always always the
same reply okay now it's a rock against
pons black will easily win this can do
both become an elite III already
considered do both an elite player so I
don't think he needs to become an elite
player alright let's check out some
other players from deeper into the
rabbit hole
um vector nope let's check out low-level
bronze Tiger all right brah they're
already in the endgame milk one corn
all right milk one corn from Portugal
has a nice position was some sort of a
some sort of a weird London system okay
going for the bishop and the pawn like
Quincy three loses the Queen don't
blunder that Mister milk corn
oh can I speak a little bit of my
language sure thing well what would you
like to hear okay now I guess you go for
the bishop okay but then there's an
in-between move yeah he saw it but then
there's this and goes after the rook huh
[Music]
why did Jelena delete her facebook
profile I have no idea too much too much
social media I guess but I mean I
wouldn't use Facebook if I if I didn't
use it for the page or or for the
messenger I think it's like it's a
terrible terrible site really lags and
it's just super slow so
all right what do we have here
well white should be completely winning
but it's a minute minute on the clock
and some seconds for both players so I
believe anything can happen here no I I
do not know Luka Modric personally the
doggie
I have no idea he was he was so around
here yeah I think I think he's chilling
in the kitchen all right so where are we
on the position here each for plate of
course now b5 yeah you don't want to
trade and now after the rook moves
somewhere you're gonna just grab it I
guess so
making a lot of progress here wood white
yeah white white wool of course
completely win this how old is he
meadow is really old like almost 15 like
14 and you know he just turned 14
Evon choke is the greatest player who
will never be world champion oh there
are there are there were a lot of
players that got that title from Paul
caressed to die with Bronstein too there
were there were a lot of them but yeah
Vasily when choke is definitely one of
them one of the stronger ones all right
really really putting the grip on black
yeah black resigns here there's there's
no move to be made like everything is
completely blocked off
five more minutes in the meadow arena
let's check out one more game from over
here and then we're gonna check up on
the leaders we've seen bronze Tiger do
at 2010 let's check out Pandu yet
neroon you say you added a pic but i
think you have to refresh the site as
there still is no profile photo all
right rooks III
okay this is this is one good game one
good game where black is up a piece but
white doesn't care
white is just gonna gonna go all out I'm
thinking g4 g5 and you know just bring
the Queen into the attack it's gonna be
wild
[Music]
sergeant setup hello man I have no idea
what a what a fridge reveal is your
hovercraft is full of eels alright ma'am
Thank You Pavan but thank you from from
India well for village to be a contender
for the World Championship he first
needs to do really well in one of the
the only way for him to qualify in the
candidates tournament if the
qualification cycle will be the same as
in the previous years is either to do
really well in the feeder Grand Prix or
to do really well in the feeder World
Cup or to to win the feeder Grand Swiss
so those are his chances of of
qualifying or if he does like extremely
well if he like has the best year and
has like the highest average rating then
he could also qualify but of course he
needs to play really really strong chess
thanks Colin for the contribution man
you still haven't said what do you want
me to say in my own language I don't
mind saying a few things but you know
most people will not understand all
right
I still think white will white can do
great things here yeah of course you
capture that but you don't trade rooks
if you trade rooks then black is pretty
much black pretty much sold all his
problems all right
dr. Johnson says even as a 200 mm rated
player I learned a lot from you thanks a
lot man
aha YouTube takes two days to update the
chats profile pictures yeah okay but
next time if I see Tarun asking to be
Ahmad you you are you will definitely be
admitted
once I have to start the video with a
dog in the chair I don't know man
man there's pretty old that I don't want
to harass him I don't I don't like it
when someone you know harasses animals
that's uh yeah okay as long as the Queen
was on this diagonal like this was
possible but you have to move the Queen
so now nasty discoveries are possible
like like night check fall by night f2
there's gonna be really cool Kalyan asks
Magnus in his prime vs. vision is prime
it's hard to say as he no one knows if
Magnus has even reached his prime but
it's it's hard to say honor in his prime
faced Kasparov plenty of times and
Kasparov was able to prevail so I don't
know I think Magnus whoever whoever in
their prime faced Magnus in their prime
that I think Magnus would would just win
do I think some I will be a grandmaster
well he will have to do a lot of
studying you know not just how to make
good chess jokes but also Sahil thanks a
lot man and we reached the end of the
meadow arena and I got matter to wins
congratulations man no he doesn't
what it's a weird ok he does he just
came here I don't know where yeah chess
world was first but then it's just yeah
good game ice rook happens to everyone
by the Argonaut or two wins with a
performance of 1757 followed by Christie
906 pants Iraq in third chess world 1612
followed by Manali attitude blindfold
chess all day movie King vena JH
cool or is it Julio and randomized
gambit intense and so on so
congratulations to all the winners of
the meadow arena and now we are going to
agamotto Friday arena let's just
withdraw from that all right we have
some very strong players here 769
players but I think we will have more
joining in and yeah if anyone's
interested I do have time for a very
short game since since we have some
three minutes before the tournament
starts so maybe maybe a nice short
bullet game or something like that
Spitfire alright Spitfire is challenging
to a bullet game alright we have time
for one alright let's let's let's do
this mr. Spitfire I'm gonna try and no
I'm not I'm just gonna play normal stuff
alright let's see what he does yes I
will capture go d5 okay let's grab that
and go here go here that's a free pawn
develop go here let's go
Oh nope no you don't let's go here and
double up the bishop will move I guess
my I'm gonna try and be faster but I'm
not doing all that well okay now I just
have two points so yeah I don't mind
that corn will nicely block
yeah I'm not I'm not interested in
giving it up just yet yeah yeah now I've
just blended everything wow that's
that's terrible yeah there there you
have it trying to save a pawn and then I
blunder the game yeah you can have it
okay
let's go here and he's so fast
this is this is terrible okay free night
now we're back in the game as he
blundered he was trying to prevent mate
on the back rank and well we just got
our past porn so we should be okay here
yeah I'll give you that form how do we
make progress how do we make progress
and how is he so fast like he's super
fast okay wow that was a that was a good
run and super fast all right let's do
another one
let's do another one and I must be much
faster this will be four here to see if
he can do this faster okay that's a free
free piece I guess that's why he is able
to play so fast as he's pre moving a lot
of the a lot of the moves yeah let's
just bring that night into the game
let's go here I guess see three now
let's go here that's some good stuff and
that's mate
all right good game that was that was
much better that was much better and
we're starting off in 30 seconds with
the main event I got mattress Friday
arena thanks a lot Paul Bristow thanks a
lot man so 15 seconds and we are almost
ready nine nine hundred and fourteen
players if anyone still Raghav Gupta
thanks a lot man
the link is in the description below if
you still want to join the tournament
we're just starting out it's going to be
90 minutes of of some excellent chess I
imagine we have women feeding master
limited arena playing
so let's see let's check out her game if
she get if she ever gets paired our
bullet isn't lame okay so we lost arena
I guess she's not being paired for some
reason okay we're gonna get back to it
who who has been paired has no one been
paired all right let's check out this
one this seems to be the only one that's
been paired air rj7 seven eight seven
seven versus the Christopher 94 all
right we have some sort of a wild wild
game here yeah we're gonna definitely
challenge that would be six at some
point any GM signed up for the
tournament no I don't think there are
any in this one we've had one in the
previous the Serbian Grandmaster Mira
mean could you join us but we might have
some in the future tomorrow you have a
tournament I linked our link to do it in
one of my videos it's like it's a
charity event for for the Mercy Hospital
inmates there they're trying to get our
funds so there will be a lot of
grandmasters playing everyone can join
so you can play against them I think
there are like 20 grandmasters already
joined in
can I increase the screen recording
quality I don't I don't think that
that's possible should be should be of
the highest quality
I do not scratch my leg at the beginning
of the video I adjust the sound it's a
very very different
am i drinking yes here is of course
doing some nice nice water thanks for
the contribution arch it yeah III don't
have like like a day job I did have one
but it got in the way of of making
videos and then I I quit my job and now
I I just do videos Vegeta we we don't
need any more mods for the moment I
believe I think we're we're good we're
good for the moment all right right
really making good good work with the
Knights is the couch behind me
comfortable yes it's it's very
comfortable it's much more comfortable
than my previous one the previous one
was it was also kind of comfortable but
it was always full of meadows Meadows
fur he's like a little shedding monster
Vivek thank you thank you Vivek yes of
course you can join everyone can still
join just click on the link in the
description below it says join Friday
arena and you are instantly playing it's
it's that simple am i planning to have
my own website yes it is actually
currently being developed by none other
than a be the the great writer of our
manga so it should be available I guess
and some maybe in a week or maybe in two
weeks time we'll see how how how long it
will take
all right that's that's a nice path bond
I guess you yeah that's ha I guess you
go in for the Queen trade here you you
go for the Queen trade you go here with
the knight to guard the pawn and if the
Queen's are traded then you can oh he's
trying to he's trying to trick him very
nice yeah trying to deliver a back rank
mate yeah why - I figured it out
punished even thanks a lot man thanks a
lot punished even YAG let's let the be
of some use okay so why did he give up
the night here
still there are back rank weaknesses
okay if now rook captures then Queen
captures night I guess no it doesn't
work does it
yeah Queen captures and then work here
it's the only way to go yeah he finds it
and now of course White has to figure
something out and quickly it's both
players are down to 20 seconds
well I don't have a water I prefer I
just drink tap water and he again
blunders background that's here's a good
game showing you the importance of
safety in the background so just a nice
h3 and the white wouldn't have issues
here but you know you can't have
everything
stock pitch all right we have stock be
sure I'm just gonna refresh this since
it doesn't seem to be showing me any
games yeah now with now we have some
games but ok let's check out this one
and then we're gonna go throughout the
entire tournament
Vito I don't think it was that exact
same move order but I believe I believe
you're talking about the game under
Lilienthal that that played it the the
famous it captures an f6 while the Queen
is hanging
ah well who was better tall or kasparov
of course in their primes it would be
one hell of a game as both of them are
incredible attacking players but you
know it's the same with every other
every other player you ask from the past
of course the the latter one will have
more knowledge of theory and he will
have much more much more success at at
playing the game Annika do you want me
to teach a bishop and Knight
checkmate all right might be I've never
done anything like that but it might be
fun it's actually not a difficult
pattern so now I guess you you go for
this or not I mean it does come with
tempo
modern-day tall oh there are a lot of
players who would would fight for that
title da ba Baba dude might be one of
them but you know there is the list goes
on do I often use chess 24 yeah I do
like for for broadcasts I use just 24
for collecting Fijians sometimes mostly
I use chess bomb for pigeons I think
they're like the quickest in delivering
free pigeons
have I ever seen ludes Boonen normal
yeah I have I'm not a fan but I have
seen it
what's this it's not much black blocks
it
and now the pawns march forward yeah
okay so he decides to push this one I'd
say it was better to push that one and
just sacrifice this one but but okay
which country has the maximum
subscribers to the channel it's still
United States but India is closing in
fast like it's still it's still United
States almost 30% but India grew from
like 10 percent last year to 17 percent
this year
and now white will just when even he's
only ten seconds on the clock but he's
gonna deliver checkmate here I would say
yeah he's just gonna Oh
don't wonder the look and now it's made
in one good game all right so let's
check out some of the other players yeah
black had it coming
Janish video mastery honors from Poland
this year let's check out a game against
Arab trini
did we have a berserk yeah we did he's
down to 40 seconds and doing very well
but still this bishop is is looking very
odd huh
do I read books yes I do not as much as
I'd enjoy sometimes I will like
sometimes I'll read a few in a month but
then like I will not read a single one
in maybe three months so it depends yeah
we're going to we're going to do the
tile game for six hundred thousand
subscribers don't worry so not not going
anywhere all right so yeah or you could
have gone for the pawn in this but yeah
Black has the black has to work fast
he's very low on time a video of your
best game alright that's an idea
no he just blundered a piece okay now
check but it doesn't really do anything
it's still winning for black but he is
down to 24 seconds if he doesn't blunder
anything okay now he grabs a pawn Janish
will will be able to do this now put
those pawns as fast as possible yeah it
looks intense but 17 seconds is enough
he's just gonna grab the knight now and
just push the coin and that's it
Raul badah badah banker he says just
subscribe good good job man
yeah it's not flagging time just yet
again Matauri no and good video man good
video on the world championship of water
sipping if you haven't seen it do check
it out on our mat arenas channel it was
I really enjoyed the part where meadow
plays the drums really really just good
stuff national master jay crossover is
playing so let's check that out
will there be another top 10 facts video
there might it really requires a lot of
a lot of hard well set I almost said a
lot of calculation a lot of editing and
you know I really hate editing which you
know you might have noticed from my
videos I never edit so I don't think
I'll be doing any more top 10 videos but
who knows maybe maybe sometimes like for
fun alright so rockin game equal
material white with the isolated past
pawn black shouldn't really have any
problems with this
at what age did I begin studying chess
seriously I've never studied just
seriously the most I've ever studied
chest was from when I was 17 to 18 I've
read I've read really a lot of books in
the in the over the course of one year I
studied the endgame I did I did a lot of
a lot of puzzles and that's that's
pretty much pretty much all I did
well I wouldn't even call that serious
but if I had to choose that was the most
serious studying I I ever did
all right so characters captures and now
yeah you go here yeah you should have
gone here I guess not allowing this but
I'm I'm also pretty sure he knows what
he's doing so we'll see
hmm okay the pan the passed pawn marches
forward but now the rook is behind the
passed pawn so no worries there
yeah now you push him back I guess Oh No
first the rook has to move okay now it's
now it's dangerous
okay I don't mind mentioning it every
time but since there are new people
joining us every day
Burger King is when you give half of
your time away but then if you win you
get more points for your victory it's
it's an you know an option leaches
introduced and people really enjoy it so
here you have a high rated player
playing against the lower rated player
and well you might choose that since
you're gonna waste time playing against
already clear that you might just world
berserk and you will get more points for
your victory this is very very intense
ah you are asking for the seventh time
who will be the world champion in the
coming years I I still think it will be
Magnus I think the only way for Magnus
for for the moment with the current
challenge he's he's getting to lose his
classical World Chess Championship title
I guess would be if he if he stops being
motivated alright otherwise I don't see
it happening yeah I mean I think there
are there might be people who would have
more chances against Magnus in a match
but to actually get that chance you
first have to win the candidates which
is you know winning a tournament is much
different than winning a match and here
Jay crossover loses as now there is
nothing more to be done here heater
grabs the pawn and loses the rook or
captures and then just the Queen so
white pulled it off good job man good
job
Arnab Kumar Mishra let's return to the
tournament who do we have here Filipino
is playing let's see let's check out his
game a queen trade and bishops of
opposite colors I imagine c4 is coming
yeah make a csgo livestream I've never
played counter-strike if that is
counter-strike
I believe it is but yeah I think it
tried it once but I I didn't enjoy it
yeah I'm black had complete advantage
what are you gonna do and Philip
blunders a piece that's not good he's up
a pond oh so we'll see what happens
could I show do the versus Carlson I I'm
pretty sure I made a video on that game
where do the one it was just uh just a
great great game really nicely prepared
line and do that played it perfectly
all right so now it's black with a
bishop I don't think I don't think there
can anything can be done here but you
never know you might try checking you
might try tricking him like this but
like this
captures this but only if black plays
poorly so we'll see when did I get
meadow some two and a half years ago
okay so oh I thought he was gonna go for
the past H pawn yeah now f5 and that's
it
that's resigns it was a valiant attempt
but it's not gonna happen who will be
the next zip champion I don't know I'm
gonna have to try harder on the next
podcast not to lose the water sippin
competition I actually thought I would I
would I only took like a half a liter of
water and I thought it would it would
not even be enough but in the end it was
jus courage analysis okay he's he's
already finished with his rook endgame
smokestack lightning we've seen a game
by him
Phoenix fire let's see there's a seems
to be a lot of action going on here with
white attacking how can okay but black
can just capture I guess capture and f6
or something
yeah what could be dangerous you kinda
don't want to put the f-bomb
so what's what's he doing okay g5
doesn't lose
since you have Queen g3 but it does look
awkward yeah okay and now like we've
said yeah f6 and then you have to kind
of worry about Bishop captures and g6
but oh yeah you just you just play a5
done and you're good to go
yeah I have five you don't allow Bishop
captors on g6 and now white doesn't
really have anything to show for sorry
yeah but he will he will try as black is
very long time
I guess you go rogue d2 simply to harass
the bishop you're not really interested
in this you don't care about g5 you
don't care about captures captures but
what you do care about is time you
shouldn't really waste so much time
Govardhan boo thanks for the
contribution and he goes for the rook
move and but he's down to 20 seconds so
it's gonna be tough against the Phoenix
Fire with 20 seconds on the clock
yeah that was a that was a nice dog lift
there we have it meadow joins the stream
all right white is now trying to figure
out how to oh yes
it's a rook trade and now you block with
the Queen and you're you're very happy
yeah black could have done better yeah
Rudy to wasn't the greatest obviously I
totally missed that
the Queen was actually guarding d2 so
now white will win simply because he's
much better on time but yeah good game
good game
black black had it but he spent too much
time even ESCO also playing in the big
tournament let's check out his game he's
uh he's also getting attacked here so
we'll see we'll see how he does
all right we have to we have to check if
this is at all interesting for for black
at some point but his King is still
stranded
he cannot capture okay now you might be
able to do it but just check yeah okay
now I guess you you saved the night but
then you might yeah it's a it's a nice
position yeah now you take the night
obviously take the night and after
captors bring the other rook into the
game and you've done better than you
might have hoped for
why are chess players considered nerds
they're not I think that's like that's a
misconception
all right now bring the rook into the
game or this is interesting
what's this what's the rook here does
this win the Queen no okay you have the
b7 pawn unprotected if if not this would
win the Queen now this this and you have
some very nice threads
the knight is sacrificed but if Y
doesn't capture it then night here
blocks this and also this is made but
yeah of course you capture the night and
that there was no reason to do that now
black is just down a rook yeah I was a
good good game by even ESCO but now he
might still win as he's very very doing
very well on time but I don't know being
down the rook
yes well said bunny with four teeth
going for the e6 pawn of course push it
now push the pawn there was there was no
no reason to do that you had to save
time by okay he is now trying to
checkmate him
of course even essa will try not not to
allow that
oh he sacrifices the rook way too early
why still has six seconds yeah and this
is now you have to go for both of the
pawns otherwise you might even risk
losing the game alright it's a flag off
check check route goes and mate yeah
now it's mate no it's not oh and it's
time out it's a draw good game even ESCO
you managed to do it good game very nice
alright who we have canary nuts I'm
pretty sure we've seen a game by him in
the previous tournament but he's not
playing all right let's see lightning
Reaper versus I'll see now Lata fee I'll
see no Lata fee even ESCO got lucky
yeah but it was also skill I mean you
have to you have to be able to draw game
being down the rook it's not not not an
easy feat
all right black created some weaknesses
here and now he will try of course to to
go after those weaknesses before white
starts an attack yeah I would wish
before maybe Queen a5 okay he goes for
the trade right away c5
okay now the knight joins the action
okay Bishop e6 yeah at some point you
you double rooks and the C file bring
the knight into the game and should be
should be promising for for black but
white also is very close to starting an
attack here okay threatening mate white
should defend against that and what is
much better on time so he should start
pushing although you can approach f5 so
it should be alright now threatening to
win the Queen with not the Queen the
rook since rook captures and Bishop
captures rook but still not not a bad
threat since black is very long time he
has to do something is it better to have
a bishop pair or a rook of course it's
better to have a bishop pair okay he
captures here to create a passed pawn
that was that was good that was very
good now the Queen comes into the game
and our black which two Queens will not
have a problem winning this even being
down to 20 seconds no I didn't finish
law school no if I finish law school I
doubt I'd be I'd be doing YouTube
Ronaldinho says doggerel some very glad
to hear that man
how to join the tournament just click on
the link in the description below and
you are in the tournament all right
so black doing very well but only three
seconds on the clock and he has to yeah
I don't think it's impossible and he
loses so he berserk but it wasn't enough
all right let's check out some of the
games martin panda martin panda let's
check out what's happening here yeah
black should be completely lost here but
of course anything can still happen ok
he now offers a queen trade i thought
maybe just bringing the rook into the
game was was cleaner
do I know how the podcast will proceed
yes I actually have the second guest for
the podcast and even the third guest for
the podcast already so we are you know
doing well regarding the podcast I am
about to make some small improvements
regarding the lighting and well maybe
maybe decorate the the scene a bit but
we'll see I'm not gonna tell you who who
the guests are just yet but you are you
are welcome to try and guess I mean I
can't stop you yeah the only difference
between Murphy and me is the degree yeah
III don't think it's the only difference
but it is an important one
yeah you want even Chuck joined last
title Thursday that he did all right so
here he Martin Panda blunders a rook
well I the rogue the exchange actually
all right yeah so it's a again down the
rook but you know you might still be
able to put some pressure maybe why it
gets really long time but not I don't
think it is possible
okay so he's trying to trick him white
still has the back rank issue so he
still needs to be careful about that
okay now Bishop e7 yes all right finally
white gets the King into the game yeah
g3 nice but now yeah I guess now route
group g7 rook f7 or something like that
well we play a tournament next Friday
yeah we will will we have a tournament
every Friday and white figures out a way
but black just blunders completely so
it's very important when you try and
flag your opponent that you you know
don't just start sacrificing right away
like you you when you think there's it's
like the perfect moment it's not you
know just try and keep the material on
for a little bit longer and you just
might be successful in flagging like
like Martin Panda is doing here but it
wasn't enough so a good game not tarnish
on your victory congratulations okay
X brave Gorka sounds sort of an in-game
I'm trying to get a game that's just
starting out okay nope nope nope seaman
Marco which nope Sheena Sheena how how
reason okay here we have a game that's
just starting out so let's let's check
it out
thanks for saying Stefan told it for the
for the contribution
what would I study if I could go back in
time I have no idea if I had my my
current knowledge probably if I had my
current knowledge about the world
probably probably something regarding I
guess I guess computers programming
maybe AI something like that do I also
play chess yes I do sometimes play chess
yes that's a free Bishop tonight covers
the bishop on d7
all right so black up a piece and white
wants to trade more pieces no I do not
paint
all right a five seemingly trapping the
bishop so white gives more material
Ramaswamy Roger asks have I ever thought
of creating my own opening yeah I think
everyone creates their own openings when
they start playing chess I think I had
one when I was just starting out I just
you know try to make everything
symmetrical like I played efore d4
Knight f3 Knight c3 Bishop c4 Bishop f4
and then just Castle I'm bringing Brooks
to d1 and e1 and it was very nicely you
know everything was nicely placed and it
too worked worked well unless I played
like against someone who could actually
play chess then they just destroyed me
I don't play in this tournament since
the reason I organized this Friday arena
is the showcase subscriber games I
thought it was a it was a nice idea
alright let's check up on some someone
else so you can have your your games
posted on the channel I don't know I
thought it was a nice idea just manga
alright we have we have a chest manga
here but no no actual games alright
looking for a game that's just starting
out yeah okay this one looks good
although there were some trades you know
after I clicked the current version of
Lila is stronger than alpha zero okay
and we've just seen made probably yeah
since the last time office 0 was
operational you know playing chess I
think yeah Lila is stronger now but if
they if they turned alpha on I think he
would overpower anything in a matter of
of a few hours we're at 45 he's playing
in every tournament and usually does
well I think he's like in top 10 in
every tournament and here he also
berserks he wants to wants to get some
points in yeah that was a very quality
game no I I do not smoke i I did smoke I
I quit two years ago two in a two years
and maybe some three months ago yeah I
think it was like two two years and two
or three months ago
my favorite character from from Mortal
Kombat its
Kung Lao definitely kumoi he's like
really really awesome with his hat and
everything
viviana Sh happy birthday man and here
we have a nice Fork
but is it a good Fork that's the
question so what's the idea behind Rocky
III you wanna you wanna grab here and
then I guess yeah after the Queen moves
yeah it still can yeah okay now you can
grab here but it's defended so you can't
yeah he wanted to grab here and then
here oh that's nasty yep that's me good
game
and that's mate a good game varada I'm
very nicely done who do we have reverse
what was that seem like yeah they just
they keep moving too fast
fresh stolen memes all right fresh
stolen memes okay but it's basically the
end of the game but I thought it was a
wild position so that's why I decided to
pick this one yeah we're gonna we're
gonna have a flag off even though black
has a queen why are you only getting
back rank mates because people you know
they don't think it can happen to them
like everyone says you should you know
you should take care of your back rank
but people are like now I mean it's not
like it's gonna happen to me
like it's like that it's like that thing
where I guess I don't know the
statistics but I've read somewhere that
like one third of every person of
everyone that rides a motorcycle will
have an accident at some point but no
one actually thinks that it can happen
to them so I think it's it's similar to
the bank back rank issues
[ __ ] from Canada let's check out J boy
Ava's yes those are just trophies behind
me that I want in my chess club and in
some local contests
all right what do we have here
white is up upon but black has a very
nice isolated past deep on so well LC
threatening to grab this so not any more
yeah I guess you go back
now I think Magnus could ever come to
the podcast yeah why not
I mean if he if he would enjoy such a
thing I don't see why not
I know he he's often he he's often on a
podcast about support but it's it's in
Norwegian so I've never seen it but you
know I don't know he might be interested
why not
where's mr. robot who's mr. robot can i
play blindfold chess
yeah I can but I've never tried more
than one game alright
good game J boy lost the silly or is it
silat maybe G Android oh that's a that's
a good point structure let's check this
out what is what is white building here
or black who is doing the building here
I'm pronouncing Vasilis name wrong okay
so it's uh it's vastly it's not Vasily
yeah because no one ever actually uses
his name so I've never known and it's
Ukrainian so I I never knew how to
pronounce it so I guess it's vastly even
shook okay that that works okay move the
bishop now so you don't lose here
captures captures and captures oh no
that's weird
oh this is some crazy stuff happening
here and now he just gave up the rook
which is weird
and that's mate Wow good stuff speed
chess 90 oh no we lost [ __ ] Barbie
Barbie Barbie Bob is he playing alright
so Oh black up black up a rope nice but
white starts pushing the past pawn yeah
that's I would say that's game but you
know 38 seconds on the clock anything
can happen
yeah I don't at the moment I don't have
any favorite youtuber since I don't
watch other videos I don't really don't
really have the time
in my younger days I was I was a big fan
of raywilliamjohnson he had this he had
this show called equals three where he
just you know reviewed some funny videos
I think I think some way somebody is
reading the chat we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to put some one timeout
for for reading the chat all right
Barbie Tibor trying to win this even
though it's okay he does it he will win
this
and yeah of course you resigned here
good job man good job all right let's
check up on our leader super GM leading
the tournament super GM from Serbia he
also played in the last tournament I
think he was second how is he doing here
yeah he berserk yes
Sam I saw my Opie Sam IOP I'm gonna have
to gonna have to organize organize a
match against sunlight to really promote
to promote the game but it's it's really
incredible how he as a stand-up comedian
is is promoting chess really on such a
such a high level organizing events with
with elite players really really
inspiring stuff sama-sama is the is the
greatest stand-up comedian he has like
he's the only person who who has chess
jokes like you you should you should
hear them they're really really
something all right super Jim trying to
win this and it's a good thing since
black has upon so you don't have to
worry about stalemate you can just you
know box the black King and as soon as
the move is made it's checkmate sharaba
is here baby boy 27 playing a nice game
so let's check that out
yeah we had a berserk from an we only
won four three two who is also in all of
the all of the previous tournaments I
believe though the engine boy I saw
daughter yesterday or was today knows
yesterday like I said already he has a
he has a baby so he's you know strolling
the baby around as you should you know
when you have a baby
yeah Chad going berserk all right I
guess it's hard too hard to say but
black should be doing well although he
doesn't really have all that many
options yeah he has to trade queens now
there is no way around that Queen a six
only move trades and it will be hard for
unknown with so little time on the clock
but on the other hand he just creates a
passed pawn and it's not gonna be not
gonna be simple for black huh
okay that was weird that was weird but
black gets his King into the game and
now white will also push okay it's gonna
be another flag off I believe yes
god bless dodo and his family well said
well said man no I wouldn't say I'm good
at science never tried it
do I want to reach a rating of 2500 of
course I mean who doesn't it yeah no not
this wow that's that's really weird yeah
six seconds yeah with the bishop there
you don't have to worry about anything
and now the the latter mating pattern is
it's called the ladder well not anymore
since you since you've bonded the Queen
and will we see a stalemate or will we
see a win and it's a stalemate yeah it
happens every time it's incredible
incredible I know it manages to with one
second on the clock he manages to avoid
loss what a stalemate Wow move a king
alright that games already finished
EXPEED alright we have a lot of whoa
that's a new window speed we have a lot
of action going on here
the people with engine cheat in online
chess yeah they do like all the time I
don't know why like you don't really
gain anything I mean of course they're
gonna they're gonna figure it out I mean
you're not gonna get away with it
people saying hi all right so what do we
have here
threatening queen h7 okay
yeah I I think there's like an algorithm
that you know figures out if someone
cheated or not but also I think if
there's like an important event going on
that it's that humans also help out in
spotting the cheaters all right black
really putting pressure on white route
d3 or yeah but then he five in that
night is not really not really a problem
1 million subscribers went well when
more people join join our community I
guess I mean there is no way you can
rush these things I don't know if I
could beat some I'd blindfolds I my
summary is you know improving his game
so I don't know I don't know what some
ice playing strength but in this
position I'll move 20 before color and
rather lost the game by checkmate
they're gonna be stats thanks for the
contribution man and super GM wins XP
loses on time but it was quite the
battle it was very intense
so who do we have let's go over from the
top once again whole house playing whole
house in 21st and he had a nice winning
streak but he just lost one whole house
against the Morningstar
fad frites 17 I don't know what the fad
Fritz 17 is that like is that like a new
Fritz engine I don't know I don't use a
local engine I use an online engine when
analyzing so III really wouldn't know
could I beat a super GN blindfold like
is that is that an actual question of
course I couldn't what do I think about
what he car was doing for the community
well I think he's doing a great job and
he's really bringing a lot of people
into chess and I've seen he's he's
getting a lot of gamers involved into
chess and was a great thing I mean manin
that after this whole coronavirus
situation that anyone who is doing
anything is interested in chess now like
the league community the hearthstone
community the minecraft community even
so it's it's a great stuff for chess in
general alright so what do you do here
the queen is hanging and also just queen
here yeah I don't think you have like a
good reply
yeah Queen g5 might have been also an
attempt but no I don't play minecraft I
tried it once just to see what you know
the fuss was about and I built one house
with a pool it was it was you know it
was pretty enjoyable like I mean because
it's building everyone enjoys building
but I didn't really see the point like
it's just an open world where you build
stuff I guess that's enough I kind of
need like therefore you know to play
something or to enjoy something I feel
like there should be a
reason or something like that maybe I
don't know that it was just what I
thought why not
twitch I don't know III realize
everyone's on twitch but i just i still
prefer youtube even for streaming
yeah I did follow Croatia in the in the
World Championship 2018 and whorehouse
loses that was a good game
Morningstar 69 wins this one tamada
alright tamada is just starting out
when will the next podcast happen I
think some maybe some 10 days from now
have to prepare a little bit not too
much if I prepare too much then I will
not be able to improvise and I really
want to improvise more so I'm just gonna
prepare light yeah I know you meant
world football Cup I did follow it yes
that's that's the only time when I when
I follow football actually so now you
want to get rid of the night and deliver
mate so black of course blocks this with
g6 and now you should okay that's not
the greatest giving upper light square
bishop but now the g6 has been played
the dark square bishop works nicely and
also you have your H pawn which you
might employ at some point I'm from
Croatia man
Domo de
Berzerk a higher rated opponent
something you don't see often but it
does happen what is that man above my
head that is a great man we should all
study this man thanks even heavy stuff
[Music]
do I speak five languages no I
exclusively speak one alright
so black blunder the Queen he tried he
tried playing faster since white is very
long time but I think we have another
case where why - just black just started
giving up material much too quickly he
thought that white didn't have enough
time just capture that bishop on d4
already okay
now with a knight against two nights
with 19 seconds I I prefer black like
just because you have more time you
don't want your knight trapped so just
capture that yeah 13 seconds it's gonna
be wild yeah I am able to speak yeah
both English and Croatian but I mostly
only speak one
three seconds and Wow and now black is
completely winning yep
that's the stuff that's the stuff you
should always be careful when Burger
King let me just check if another hunk
is he playing let's check out the game
by na drunk he's playing axis of death
so let's see how he's doing
there's a threat on the on the h2 pawn
so he should definitely defend against
that but he doesn't so not okay but
black not interested in snatching that
phone right away
yeah black is not interested in that
pawn he's playing some very very active
chess
who is the man above my head I I will
let the chat answer that okay and now we
have the the capture King each one is a
must and then we have some nasty
discoveries too bad you the queen is not
on a dark square so now you you can
claim a draw by threefold repetition
just repeating Bishop g3 check and go
back or you might try to find a way of
how to exploit this but there doesn't
seem to be a good way like if you could
get some a few moves in you might be
able to do it but if the knight comes
off yeah you're gonna have to suffice
for a draw here and Abbie Abbie gets a
draw here against that much higher rated
opponent yeah of course you have to go
for it and bishop g3 is yeah a draw by
is threefold repetition good game Abbie
and good game access of death let's
check out who we have bad Oh
Morningstar we've already seen palanquin
wood wood chopping okay here's an
interesting position let's check out
that one
how do I feel in Croatia lost I'm not I
wasn't really too involved in it I mean
I enjoyed watching it and everyone was
really hyped since you know it's your
country playing but of course I had to
choose who would win I'd prefer Croatia
to win but you know after that first
moment where they lost then later it was
okay but it didn't affect me all that
much
yeah the man above my head is Bobby
Fischer obviously everyone knows that do
I know
Narendra Modi it's the the Indian Prime
Minister I believe
do I have a regular job yes I do
yeah this is this is the regular job no
but this is this is just for fun for for
the job can't really call it a job since
you know people most people don't enjoy
their job I really I really enjoy what I
do so I wouldn't really call it a job
more of a more of a more of a thing I do
that's also you know financially viable
okay now this could be a problem
Queen g'wan might be might be an idea
but he goes for night captures an h2
first how do I know Modi I think I
follow him on Twitter that he's very
very active on Twitter yes the morphe
saga is still being made however we are
taking a small break due to all of the
tournaments that are happening online
am i subscribe to PewDiePie no I'm not I
do check up on his oh that's a nice mate
g5 mate good job
I knew it wins it I'm not subscribed but
I do check up on his videos like once a
year to see what what's he up to as he
is the biggest YouTube ok now I believe
t-series is the biggest on YouTube but
they're like a corporation or an entity
like when it comes to just like a
one-person show he's still the biggest
and I do check up on what's what's he
doing but it's not not really my thing
but what's this banana duckling style
one alright not playing any games at the
moment undercover yogi also not playing
any games
silver owl let's check out silver owl
yeah I have more I have more pillows
which I thought I'm just gonna you know
switch between them I have like the one
with the shades I have the one who
that's you know like winking I have the
one that's crazy I have the the loving
one the funny one but I never I never -
I never a her switch between them okay
so check and pick up the rook that's a
good spot white will not be happy about
that one
do I think men and women should compete
separately no no I don't but I also
don't think like we could just eliminate
the woman's chest it would be able to
create chaos but over the course of some
let's say maybe 20 years I don't know
that we should you know strive towards
you know merging the two somehow
yeah f5 was not possible here do I play
ball with meadow me there's not really a
ball guy you know sometimes I throw him
stuff but he's just like you know
whatever you know throw throw them all
you want
an airplane crashed in Pakistan I've
never never heard about it today yeah
that's that's that's terrible if it if
it was you know if it had passengers
then that's really bad lower entry
requirement yeah I think what do you
mean lower like 1500 huh
can I do the Dutch defense a Ruthie the
magma cube thanks for the contribution
what do you mean can I do the dodge
defense do I play it I did I did try to
employ it from time to time I tried the
the stone wall yeah I did enjoy it but I
kind of decided against it
and I was just trying out D mostly when
I when I have to play a real game I I
will go for the nimzo-indian yeah I've
never played for players chess but as
Sam I invited me oh that's bad the
bishop covers that's mate yeah too bad
too bad for silver are well good game by
Daniel circus well you know I've never
tried for play chess but someone invited
me to join him along Aleksandra botas
with it and and onigiri the player for
four-person chess so I've never tried it
but should be fun
I mean I've seen people play it so I I
guess I guess it is fun
they don't play it for no reason I would
guess an Argand matter with two R's all
right but not playing how about a hobo
dog hobo dog but that the game is
already pretty much over
King Leon from Germany Raja Leon not
playing everyone's in in pause mode even
ESCO is he playing ok let's check up on
him since we only checked up on the on
the ending of this game so doing well
let's see let's see what happens
why Anna and Carson are not in this
tournament I think they're you know they
they're pretty busy which laptop model
am i using I'm not using a laptop it's
it's a desktop PC but I do have a when I
go somewhere like when I travel and I
have to record on my travels I I do have
a predator I think it's a Helios 300 to
use in my travels have I finished
studying the red you know I've only
covered like three lines like I've
covered a night of 3d five and C four
obviously the one that Maxime played
against me which I totally blundered
with night of six but I'm now playing it
with if if you know whitey decides to go
with that move order
I found that night of 3d 5c4 and D for
just advancing the pawn will do nicely
and also I've checked on on the main
line like night of 3d five and just G to
the the Kings Indian attack how to play
that and also I've checked some trans
positions where like neither 3d 5d four
where you kind of always transpose into
the Queens gambit declined how to do
that properly and maybe pick a really
safe line of the Queens gambit declined
so I'm trying to lower the amount of
variations that I have to learn in order
to play against the reti
but when I'm done or when I'm done
studying it I will gladly present my
findings in a video
all right three against two pawns on the
kingside let's see let's see it's always
it's always intense for white to try and
draw this Milind Anand has the same
laptop yeah it's a good laptop how do I
not lose motivation playing chess well
it's I don't play chess all that much
and I don't think anyone can lose
motivation playing chess like it's I
think in in taos book life in games of
Michael Tao he he starts the he starts
the book with like sort of a foreword
saying that once you you've been
infected with the chest virus there's
there's no going back
like many have tried but you know
abandoning chest but they always they
always return to it
how often do I practice chess very
rarely like sometimes when I get really
motivated I will you know do some work
but unfortunately it's very rare I mean
now unfortunately if I wished I would
have you know studied more but you can't
you can't do everything
Haruko welcome language yummy Cola if I
ever visit Czech Republic I'm definitely
gonna do a meet-up and you know I heard
I heard you guys have some good beer all
right
even ESCO is trying trying trying
Abhinav with six seconds on the clock
and now check and pick up the rook
that's the stuff ya know take the rook
check and take the rook even ESCO take
the rook dude
[Music]
he draws that was weird
yeah he didn't he didn't see that he
could grab the rook and he he wanted
that draw against the high rated
opponent but okay good game man
do I think games like pop G keep kids
keep gay kids away from the chest no I
don't who is interested in chess we'll
play chess I mean I sometimes play some
other games like hearthstone
battlegrounds I play I play that but
it's totally totally different I mean
you play chess chess is like the
ultimate skill game there is no there's
no random generated content there's no
luck there's no anything like that but
it's also the most frustrating when you
lose because you know that it's only
your fault that you lost there's there's
no one else to blame
well when you play other games you know
anything can happen so you know you can
just enjoy it's much more chill so it
doesn't have to be your fault when you
lose so it does have its its benefits I
would say even gaming BG vs. a doctor
profound 365 existential smick there you
have it man
I really couldn't suggest a book on
theory as I haven't done any serious
work on the book and who work on theory
like most of my opening knowledge comes
from
borislav Eve coves book center for chest
improvement in Belgrade like there's
opening Theory one opening theory too
and the theory on end games so that's
that's where I you know gained most of
my knowledge like in a condensed way
okay this is now very unpleasant so I
don't know if I can suggest any night
captures that was weird
now you you kind of give black a new
lease on life which Grand Master doesn't
get enough credit oh that's a nice
that's nice Fork yes he who dares wins
Allen we thanks for the contribution and
if I ever visit I mean it's hard of
course for me to personally contact
everyone but any place I visit I will
make a get-together or of course publish
it on my channel and you guys can all
come and we can we can chill you know
play some games and stuff like that
please do something with audio I'm
pretty sure the audio is fine like or
rather it should be fine
well I I wouldn't say Carlson's
performance is decreasing his winning
really I mean he's winning every event
he's playing in so I wouldn't say his
performance is decreasing but he's he's
trying to have a more fun try trying out
new openings and I I do believe that you
know bothering you know struggling with
organizing stuff and you know thinking
about things other than chests of course
does take a toll on your game but he
still won't the 1d Invitational he still
now managed to get into of course the
knockout phase of the indoor asabi rapid
challenge which now it's like as as he
reached the knockout phase now he it's
the same for everyone so he can still
win it's all right I wouldn't say that
anything is declining how much money do
you get by making videos well it all
depends there's no there's no simple way
to answer that it all depends on how
many people watch it who watches it from
where at what time you know how how long
does a person stay watching one video
there are like a million parameters who
was the better attacker tall order
Rashid
well Rashid was definitely the the more
spectacular attacker however if you
paired him against the really really
strong defenders like I don't know maybe
maybe Tigran Petrosian or someone like
that
I don't he wouldn't really fair all that
well or even you know that the famous
saying when near Modena played against
Allah Allah gave ski where Paul gave ski
like he said that he would trade a
doesn't wins he the where he defeated
the near Modena for the one winded who
were in his Medina defeated him as just
a brilliant brilliant game so Nino is
definitely the better attacker
but tall is able to you know use his
mastery and magic to crush much stronger
opponents do I have ADHD no I don't or
rather I don't think I do alright so we
are down to our last ten minutes and
let's check out the standings it's super
GM still in first with 75 points so it's
not going to be easy for anyone to read
a catch up to him Yona in third I am
mate checkmate in second you po6 won all
then palanquin we haven't seen a game by
palanquin just yet so let's see what's
he up to
he's traded Queens and now we're in some
sort of an end game where yeah you have
to trade not to lose the pawn we're
gonna see it's a bishop pair against a
bishop and the night so I like black but
we'll have to wait and see what happens
now currently lockdown doesn't affect me
in any way since lockdown is over in
Croatia we didn't really we didn't
really struggle all that much I mean we
did but compared to other countries we
didn't like we had I think we had like
two 2000 confirmed confirmed cases and
almost all of them were have
successfully recovered like not all of
them like maybe nine 1950
yeah still I'm from Croatia it's a very
small town here in Croatia called Cree
shift-z yes I would most definitely
consider a Viktor Korchnoi saga but you
know first we have to finish this saga
then when we cover all the all the
current events that are happening then
you guys will have to vote again then
we'll probably vote again under will it
be an alien saga maybe a unipolar saga
maybe a cautionary saga maybe a carp of
saga although maybe it could be a bit
too early for a carp of saga well we'll
see
do I make a living only through chess at
the moment yes at the moment yes but not
not obviously not through playing chess
by by promoting it but now I am trying
to you know do more promote more
that's why I've started the podcast that
we are publishing our chess manga very
soon so it will be another another nice
way maybe to promote chess I don't know
how people will react to it I think it
will be a positive reaction I mean why
not a nice story nice characters you
know and there's also chess so it's like
imagine if you if there was chess in the
movie matrix I mean who wouldn't watch
that I am saying
I've almost been to the US last year but
I didn't go in in the last moment I was
supposed to go to the cyma simultaneous
exhibition that magnus carlsen was
holding in what's what's it called it's
near Madison Square I think it's the
Crystal Palace but then something
happened and I couldn't go
oh I still am not gonna disclose who is
the next guest on the podcast but I will
in a few days on the channel and also on
other social media like Twitter so you
guys will again be able to post some
questions I didn't I didn't use most of
your questions last time as they were
there were some excellent questions but
I don't know I feel kind of weird asking
a super Grandmaster what's your favorite
piece I mean I might I could be in the
wrong here but it kind of it's almost
like I don't know something you would
maybe ask a toddler so I don't know all
right let's see how Jana she's doing but
okay it is a it is a pretty wild
position against Klaus Klaus sure yes
Irina will prepare my sipping game has
to improve like like a lot this is
unacceptable
like like who said like Matthew
McConaughy says it in a wolf of
wallstreet those those are rookie
numbers I believe he says it
why is the channel named Ivan Madar
well that's that's a secret
neither another wrong is a B is the he's
the writer behind our chest manga the
genius
Gujarati versus Gujarati versus onigiri
what about that and Janish wins on time
but also in a better position so all is
fair that ends well
all right let's check up on another one
from here Sonia we haven't seen his game
and then we're gonna return to the title
leaders tell the yella not to stop
playing the Scandinavian Scandinavian is
the is the best like I don't know I
really enjoy it for black like in every
time format until I get until I get much
better in playing the Sicilian I'm also
doing some work on the sveshnikov now
but I still feel much more comfortable
in the Scandinavian motors queue let's
check out modest yeah French is better
but I've never I've never tried playing
the French since I just feel like it
would be it would be you know
self-torture I might be wrong but I will
try it at some point
Samuel is a girl's name okay my bad how
can I prepare so quick for the games
played to review on YouTube well I watch
I watch the games live so I don't I mean
I prepare the game while I'm watching it
and then when it ends I I already have
it prepared it's not really not really
anything spectacular ok so that do you
win a pawn and give up your dark square
bishop and the white is down a whole
rook so that's that's pretty bad for our
friend mod askew
will I cover any little a 2-0 games well
I
seen I've seen Danny wrench made a game
I made a video on one of the games that
Lila just played so I haven't seen it I
don't know where the game is from
probably oh that's a nice mate
probably for from the chest calm
computer Chess Championship but I
haven't seen the game yet
how do you join the leeches battle arena
well we are we are almost finished like
there's a one minute left for for the
arena with 1600 players but every Friday
like for those of you who are not
familiar with what we're doing here
every Friday there are two tournaments
meadow arena and the Friday arena you
guys are playing and I'm showcasing your
games and then well we're just enjoying
it just manga are you playing currently
yeah but it's already over a swim PO my
Z not playing we've seen a game by him
nothing happening here meth meth cooks
okay this one seems to be going on okay
no I still haven't visited India and at
the moment it's not possible okay so now
if rook f1 yeah like what are you Queen
here or here that's even better but you
don't have this as its defended twice so
might have been better to do this right
away oh yeah that hurts yeah yeah you
couldn't capture this because check and
you pick up the Queen so that was also
in the position but now just now pick up
the knight and this is mate if Black
gets a move okay
so white figured it out it's gonna be
it's gonna be a flag off
Tarun I'm not I'm not at liberty to
discuss anything from the chest manga I
would I would really hate to spoil
anything for you guys as you know it's
we've been preparing it for so long so I
would hate to spoil anything so we've
reached the end of our tournament the
top ten players are so out of 1600 and
31 players super GM won first place
I believe he's from Serbia eeeh then we
have I am mate
checkmate from the Czech Republic then
we have uh No 14:32 then freedom master
janosh MB then you post 6-1 Oh palanquin
stalemate nine patrol a gun dev seven
eight nine and Sam Aleph so those are
those are those are the winners I mean
everyone's a winner but those are the
top ten winners of the arena so
congratulations to everyone and once
again congratulations to the winners of
the meadow arena a good matter to
Panther Rock and Kristy 9:06 so I will I
will probably publish the winners on my
social media and on my next YouTube
video so we can once again congratulate
everyone so that's it for for this
stream I do hope you guys enjoyed it and
I hope you hope to see you in the next
one as well we I don't think we've had
like 2000 people in the tournament but
we are getting closer to the number so
it's a good good to see that the
tournament is growing but yeah and once
again I do hope you enjoyed it thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
thanks a lot guys I'm sorry it's not
Czech Republic it's Poland my bad
I assumed yeah I assumed because it's
I'm me to checkmate that he's from Czech
Republic yeah but it's Poland sorry guys
okay till next time